an arrest has been made in that bizarre
case of two missing children and their
mother who ran off to Hawaii during the
investigation
prosecutors are describing lori valo as
a flight risk as she made her first
court appearance on Friday Jonathan
Vigliotti reports from Hawaii
Lori valo is in a Kauai jail cell
her bail set at five million dollars for
months valo has been living in Hawaii
with her new husband Chad de Bell who
sources tell CBS News was also
questioned by police he was not arrested
police have said valo and de bel have
lied about the children's whereabouts I
want to know where JJ and Ty Lee are and
whatever they have to do to give us as
family members that closure Amy pushing
is Toby Ryan's aunt hopefully she will
come to the conclusion that just coming
clean will be the best path for her
because Lauri is only going to act in
the best interest of Lori valo faces
several serious charges deserting her
children and delaying legal attempts to
locate them each count carrying a
possible 14 years in prison another
charge contempt of court for not
physically producing her children to
authorities in Idaho as ordered
authorities are also investigating three
suspicious deaths connected to the
couple de belles wife Tammy Valor's
estranged husband Charles and Bala's
brother Alex Cox who killed Charles and
later died of unknown causes himself but
for Cushing the children come first
we still potentially have a long road
ahead of us but we are hopefully one
step closer to finding Ty Lee and JJ and
CBS News has learned more from
investigators about what led up to Lori
Veloz arrest her financial records
reveal not a penny has been spent on
child care since they disappeared in
September
also prescriptions for JJ's autism
medication have gone unfilled valo is
fighting this extradition her next court
appearance set for March 2nd for CBS
this morning Saturday Jonathan Lodi
Hawaii so sad second in case and we were
saying as we were watching that where
the good where are they you know could
they possibly be alive you know
battles the question we certainly hope
so not imagine the heartache of that
family right now